in a world where Hillary Clinton's
emails were the subject of FBI
investigations and countless Republican
investigations and count countless
instances of propagandizing the
narrative has actually continued to be
that Donald Trump is going to be really
responsible for the handling of
information while we should still be
investigating Hillary Clinton and yet
the facts are completely opposite to
that we know that Ivanka Trump was using
private email even for things related to
government dealings and we've now
learned that Donald Trump's son-in-law
Jared Kushner is allegedly using the app
whatsapp for White House business
including when talking to foreign
governments this is a national security
danger this is a cybersecurity danger
this completely exposed as Jared Kushner
to foreign espionage as if he wasn't
already exposed to that when we learned
more about the personal email use by
Ivanka Trump she reportedly switched to
government email once it was reported
doesn't appear as though that change has
taken place with Jared Kushner and
whatsapp Clint Watts is a former FBI
agent and senior fellow at George
Washington University's Center for cyber
and homeland security he says that this
is clearly undoubtedly much worse than
the entire Hillary Clinton's emails a
story saying quote we heard emails lock
her up emails lock her up to me
Kushner's alleged use of whatsapp is far
more egregious this is foreign business
interactions and by the way it's being
blocked from other parts of the US
government this means foreign leaders
have a better understanding about what
the White House is communicating than
our own intelligence community our own
law enforcement and our own allies this
puts us in a very dangerous position
because as an executive branch or
legislative branch we really don't know
what's going on at the top and we have
no oversight of it obviously this is
worse than what Hillary did but I
questioned whether it's even worth
wasting time on it and
don't know Pat if this is my cynicism or
pessimism or whatever but what I mean is
that they're not going to face
consequences right I mean from said
Hillary's emails the real issue is Jared
and Ivanka and Reince Priebus and
kellyanne's private email and whatsapp
use it's Trump spilling secret
information from an ally to a Russian
spy recruiter in the Oval Office
Hillary's the one who they say should
have been locked up they're never going
to actually be convinced that what their
own people are doing is worse
so I question whether this is even
worthwhile to talk about because on the
one hand I have to report to you that as
usual the truth is the opposite of what
they claim they claim it's all about
Hillary's emails their communications
are the ones that we should be concerned
about from a national security
perspective but we know they don't care
Pat so should I even bother yeah I mean
they seem to know that there's not going
to be any consequences and that's why
they're being so brazen about it like
Jared Kushner understands the double
standard going on where Trump criticized
Hillary Clinton's use of a private
server and then it turns out that so
many people in Trump's White House are
using private email also there's so much
criticism over him and his security
clearances you think you would lay low
you think you would play it by the book
but he's not you know they're they're
just this brazen and I think we do have
to keep reporting it but we have to do
so with the caveat that nothing's going
to come out of this yeah I mean it's
it's just voting in 2020 that they will
all go away if we vote them out this is
not even a blip for the right the right
doesn't care nothing will happen
this guy Kushner is still employed by
the White House he's doing this now this
is a national security threat now but
why would they stop doing any of this
stuff if they're not going to face any
consequences if you are an
administration official and you're
getting away with everything why would
you stop when this broke Fox News was
100% ready to cover it and by cover it I
mean they were ready to cover it up as
soon as news of this Jared Kushner
whatsapp Fiasco broke you go to Fox
news.com they have a story about
Hillary's emails they have a piece about
how bad
this sanctuary cities are they had a
piece about Trump employing more women
than Obama did no mention of george w
bush by the way straight-up propaganda
carefully calibrated to prevent critical
stories from getting any oxygen and
that's why i think that's right i'll
keep telling you that this is going on
but i will be very frank and transparent
with you that we can't expect actual
consequences and the only way to get
them all to go away is by voting them
out in november and i hope every single
person in the audience plans to do that
one of today's david pakman show
sponsors is simple habit an app that
provides a massive library of really
excellent five minute guided meditations
they're letting everybody in our
audience use it completely free for one
week when you go to simple habit comm
slash Pakman we've talked a lot on the
program about the growing scientific
evidence pointing to the benefits of
meditation and what really sets simple
habit apart is the variety of guided
meditations that they offer more than
2,000 made for many different issues
that you may be dealing with if you need
help
falling asleep if you have anxiety that
you're dealing with if you want to be
more productive during the day they have
meditations specifically tailored for
certain times of day like when you're
waking up or your commute to work or
when you've just gotten home from work
I'm a huge advocate of meditation myself
I've really enjoyed integrating simple
habit into my day and each meditation
takes just five minutes and they're very
easy to follow maybe you want to feel
more grounded before you start your day
at work or at school maybe you want to
keep your mind a little more clear so
that it's easier to accomplish your
goals or you just want a calmer more
peaceful experience throughout your day
simple habit can help you get there
it just won the 2018 Google Play award
for best well-being app it's available
on Android iOS and web browser and you
can try it completely free for a week
check it out go to simple habit comm
slash Pakman I've put a link down below
on
the video